قتلى وجرحى غالبيتهم من الاطفال والنساء
جراء استهداف قوات النظام تجمعا لمخيمات
النازحين قرب بلده كفر جالس بريف ادلب
الغربي قوات النظام استادفت هذه المخيمات
بحسب قوات المعارضه بصواريخ محمله بقنابل
عنقوديه محرمه دوليا وربما هذا ما يفسر
كثره الاصابات في صفوف النازحين من
الاطفال والنساء تبعا للشضايا الكثيره
التي تنتج عن هذه القنابل فرق الدفاع
المدني اجلت المصابين والجرحى الى
المستشفيات تخصصيه في مدينه ادلب وايضا
عملت هذه الفرق على التخلص من مخلفات
القنابل العبوديه التي انتشرت بين خيام
النازحين ايضا هذا الاستداف ادى الى
اندلاع حرائق في مخيمات النازحين وحاله من
الخوف همم كانت
متواجده بين العائلات همم الكثير منهم همم
لجا الى الاحراج المجاوره من هذه المخيمات
من تكرار الاستهداف من قبل قوات النظام
هذا ليس الاستئناف الاول لمخيمات النازحين
بحسب فرق الدفاع المدني وانما كان هناك
ثقافات سابقه خلال الاشهر الماضيه
ادام ابو حسام الجزيره